Behind the scenes
of every movie you love
years of planning have gone into making sure that
every line, prop and camera angle are exactly what the film makers want.
The crazy thing about movie making though,
is that sometimes, even when with all the planning
the film makers and actors decide to
toss out the script and improvise instead.
Sometimes this can be disastrous, but other times these unplanned moments turn out to be seriously awesome.
For this video, we're taking a look at some of the best,
for our list of ten improvised movie scenes that made actors react out of nowhere.
Enjoy this video and be sure to hit the subscribe button for more awesome ScreenRant content every single day of the week.
...key to success in this racket is this little baby right here, it's called cocaine
The Wolf of Wall Street
Matthew McConaughey had himself a pretty good 2013.
Not only did he take home the Best Actor Oscar for Dallas Buyers Club,
he also delivered a quick but quality performance in The Wolf of Wall Street.
Fans loved the scene where McConaughey was banging his chest.
[humming and thumps]
And as it turns out, this is something the actor made up on the spot.
The ritual was actually something McConaughey would do before shooting,
and he decided that he would bring it into the scene.
Leonardo DiCaprio is a world-class actor, but you can totally see him cracking up,
and even looking over to the camera crew as McConaughey's chest beating and humming escalates.
Zoolander
While 2016's Zoolander sequel was an absolute travesty,
the original film is actually quite hilarious,
and is jam-packed with fun, unscripted moments.
-I guess so.
In one scene involving David Duchovny and leading man Ben Stiller,
Duchovny's character is explaining how the fashion industry has been behind every high-profile political
assassination of the last hundred years.
Stiller's Zoolander asks "Why male models?", which prompts Duchovny to give a  long and clear explanation.
Stiller then stares right at him, and again asks,
"But why male models?"
"You serious? I just..."
"I just told you that a moment ago."
As it turns out, this moment happened because Stiller actually forgot his line,
and just opted to repeat his previous one.
The scene was totally unplanned, but thanks to Duchovny's great reaction, it ends up fitting in perfectly.
The Dark Knight
The Dark Knight is still regarded as  one of the best superhero movies of all time,
and Heath Ledger's Joker performance has become even more iconic as the years have gone on.
[Wham!]
Ta-da! It's- ahh, it's gone.
It's well known that Ledger threw himself deep into the role,
and this led to some pretty amazing unscripted moments.
"Do I really look like a guy with a plan?"
A lot of people already know about the improvisation in the scene where the Joker blows up the hospital,
but there was also a great unscripted moment from when the Clown Prince of Crime
is locked up behind bars.
As the officers in the room applaud Commissioner Gordon's promotion,
Ledger begins, totally off-script, to slowly clap,
and staring through the prison bars with a truly terrifying look.
It was just a simple improvisation, but it totally changed the vibe of the scene,
and has become an iconic moment  from the film.